let's get started with keyword research
so basically what we want to do is
center our keywords just like our
website we want to center our keywords
around or our content around good
keywords so
the videos on youtube are no different
than the web pages on our website
so if we have somebody who states
youtube is the world's second
most well well-known engine well it is
because it's right behind google it's
not a search engine per se
it's a video platform but if it was a
search engine
it'd probably be second right behind
google so
youtube is pretty popular majority
people
use youtube search every day to watch
videos on
a number of different topics so they can
find these videos in google
but because youtube's so powerful and so
popular people go directly right
into youtube for their searches and so
the whole
idea behind youtube being the second
most well-known search engine
is centered around keywords so if you
have the right keywords for your video
then the chances of you ranking higher
increases on youtube
so we're gonna share with you a few easy
ways to do
keyword research this is the most
important step
in getting your videos to rank on
youtube just like
for those of you who watched any of the
seo videos we produced at simplylearn
you know that keyword research is so
essential to
getting your web pages to rank on google
well it's no different keyword research
and choosing the right keywords is just
as important
for your videos as is for your web pages
so we're going to go
into a few things to do here to
find the right keywords so we have the
search suggestion
you can look at your competitors we have
different tools we can use some other
factors involved in google itself so
let's start talking about
some of these ways to really hone in and
do some
good research on your keywords to align
them with your videos
first thing is search suggest so youtube
has a feature called autocomplete so
if you've done any searches on google
it's very similar
if you're typing something in to youtube
search
then youtube is going to suggest other
related popular keywords so let's take a
look at that
if we go back to youtube for a second
and i just type in
machine learning youtube is going to
populate on the autocomplete in the
search bar some other
popular keywords that we can potentially
use
or in this case if i choose you know
machine learning tutorial
i'm gonna see a video about machine
learning tutorial so here you can see
simply learns ranked number one for
machine learning tutorial but there are
other videos that show up in my search
result
so we want to be able to use the search
suggestion
box in the search box field so when
we're typing in something
you know youtube just like on google is
going to give us those suggestions so
if we're focusing a video on machine
learning then
you know we have some ideas of some
other keywords that we could center
around
because these are our popular keywords
these are keywords that
people are using to search on youtube so
that's one suggestion
looking at competitors is another
suggestion so we could search for
keywords
used by our competitors in their video
and title and description so let me
talk a little bit about that what you
want to do is you want to go to
that particular channel of your
competitor so when you go to your
particular competitor's youtube channel
you want to be able to
click on the videos tab when you click
on the videos tab then you're going to
sort by most popular
and then what you could do is see a list
of videos
and then when you look at a list of
videos you're going to choose a video
and then what you're going to do then is
take a look at the keywords
used in the title and description and
then once you do that
you're going to have a list of keywords
that you can use yourself
for that video so for example let's go
back to youtube
so if i go to type in simply learn
here's their channel page just by
clicking on simply learn
i click on videos ever wonder if there's
so now i can see all of this ever wonder
if there's an
easier way go back so here i can see all
the videos
sort by most popular once they do that
then i could choose a video
this is the most popular video right now
for simply learn if i click on that
video
it's automatically going to start
playing but what i could do
is simply just look at you know the
content description
so just by clicking show more i can see
all the content
that align with this video that's one
way to do it
is simply by looking at your competitors
now what you could also do
is look at the tags associated with the
particular video
and so what you want to do is you want
to
look at the html and so that means
looking at the page source
so just like web pages what youtube does
is they look at meta tags
so if you call from seo in order to get
your pages to rank
you need to have a title tag and a meta
tag description so videos are no
different
what we're doing uh for youtube is
aligning
certain keywords with the video so if
you take a look
and do a search for keywords by viewing
the page source
you're going to see all the keywords
associated
with a particular video so for example i
go back to youtube
and i look at the page source of a video
let's just say this video here
facebook's ad tutorial i'm going to pull
up the page source and all i need to do
is
control f and type in keywords and now
for that facebook video i can see
all the keywords associated with the
video so you can see there's a lot of
different keywords we're aligning with
this video
and so why do we want to do that because
we want
you know our video to show up for
keywords that people may
type in and so if you use that youtube
autocomplete
it's going to give you those ideas this
most popular keywords
so if they're related align those
keywords with the video so here you can
see facebook marketing
facebook ad strategy facebook ads for
beginners
so forth and so on so there's a lot of
keywords we've aligned here
with that particular video and again all
you need to do
is look at the page source so right
clicking
view page source do a control f for
keywords
and you'll be able to see the keywords
aligned so you could do that
for your competitors videos as well so
you can see what keywords your
competitors using
for a video that's most popular for
their channel
and is also ranking on youtube and on
google
so using the autocomplete gives you
those keyword ideas
looking at your competitors videos also
gives you some other ideas
for keywords that you can align with a
video that's relevant
that you want to rank for so let's look
at uh
some other ideas here so you can install
plugins
and there are plenty of plugins
available on the chrome browser
that will help you see the video tags
associated with a particular video
so a couple of examples of vid iq and
tubebuddy
those are extensions that work in chrome
and what they do is they give you the
exact
tags that a particular video is using so
for example
if i go back here and i look at a video
on youtube let's just say
the machine learning basics video i have
vid iq
installed on my chrome browser so just
by clicking on that
vid iq is going to give me a lot of
information about that video they're
just going to give me an overview of
their particular
metrics they're going to give me some
other information associated with
facebook some engagement metrics
really what i'm interested in is those
keywords
so if i scroll down a bit here i can see
the video tags associated with the
machine learning basics video so
vid iq is telling me is these keywords
are associated with this video and not
only does it show me what
keywords are associated i can also see
where they rank so for machine learning
basics this particular
video ranks number one if i go down i
can see
what is machine learning and how does it
work i can see it's ranked number two
here i can see
machine learning algorithms it's ranked
number nine so
i can get some ideas of the types of
keywords
that are being used as tags for that
video further down i can also see some
channel tags but really this is the
video tags or the idea place i want to
be able to look to get an
idea of the types of keywords that are
associated with the video
that are also ranking or not ranking so
that's another way
for you to really get an understanding
of
what keywords to use at the particular
video so auto complete
you can look at the page source of a
competitor's video or you can use a
chrome extension in this case i'm using
vid iq
to give me some information about the
video tags for a particular video so
according to
an industry study using keywords and
video tags
will help you rank well on youtube so
you have to use keywords and video tags
if you want your video to rank there's
been a lot of studies youtube is so
popular and videos are so prominent in
today's world
where if you have videos and you're
going to upload them to youtube then
associate the right keywords
with those videos so some important
factors
when we look at keywords what we want to
do is look at search volume we want to
look at competition
we want to look at relevancy we want to
look at the primary and secondary
keywords that we want to use so
well chosen keywords will help you rank
so we just gave you some ideas
on how to do some keyword research again
those ideas were
really to use the autocomplete on
youtube or google they're going to give
you some popular keywords
you can look what your competitors are
doing by looking at the page source
and just looking at the keywords that
are aligned with that video
or you can use a third-party extension
in chrome
in my example i use vid iq that gave me
the keywords
associated with that video so you have
ways to get the keywords
so what we want to do is we want to make
sure we choose keywords with high search
volume they're going to drive more
traffic to your video however we want to
balance that out with keywords
that have low difficulty and are easier
to rank for so you don't want to choose
something very broad
that's just going to be very difficult
to rank for and of course we always want
to go with relevancy
so for talking about machine learning
basics then we
want to choose keywords associated with
that and that's where that autocomplete
comes in handy because
what google's going to do and youtube's
going to do is give us keywords that are
very closely related to the video that
we're trying to optimize for
and so we have a number of different
keywords at our disposal
that are relevant that we can look to
see if they have
good volume and low competition and so
the whole idea is we want to choose a
keyword that defines the nature of the
content
and then what we want to do is support
that with secondary keywords so
we want keywords that are highly
relevant to the primary keyword so
that's the way
to go about aligning your keywords you
want keywords that
are high volume low competition are
relevant
and you want to choose that one keyword
that is really what the content's about
and then those secondary keywords that
support the primary so
if you have a machine learning video you
could choose your primary keyword as
in this case the machine learning basics
video so well chosen keywords
help you rank well on youtube just like
the machine learning basics so if i go
back to our video
our machine learning basics video if i
just type in
machine learning basics i'll be able to
pull it up and so here it is
i click on it i'm going to go to youtube
and so here i can see
this keyword we know humans learn from
their is well aligned because
it's in the title it's in the copy and
it's
aligned as a keyword tag with the video
so we know that that keyword has good
volume
low competition is relevant because
that's what the video is about the
basics of machine learning
it's an introduction to machine learning
so instead of
honing in on just introduction machine
learning
primary keyword is machine learning
basics and then we supported that video
with those secondary keywords
what is machine learning because
somebody who doesn't know machine
learning
is probably going to type in that
keyword and then introduction of machine
learning is a good
secondary keyword because it's
explaining the basics
of what machine learning is all about so
primary keyword machine learning basic
secondary keywords what is machine
learning and introduction to machine
learning
so that's the whole idea behind choosing
keywords you want that
keyword that really is going to define
the content and then support that with
those
secondary keywords so remember when
you're performing your keyword research
choose keywords for your videos that
google shows on the video results page
so what i mean by that is your video can
get more views if you rank on google as
well so the whole idea is not
necessarily to be found on youtube it's
also to be found on google
so if i go back to google and i just
type in data science for beginners
and i type in videos then you can see
we're ranked number one so
even if you're not looking at the videos
clicking on the videos link on google
search
you can always just when you do a search
what google's going to do is also
put in the videos here on par as part of
the search results so what they're going
to show you
is the top videos that are ranking for
that particular keyword
and so we may not rank overall
for data science for beginners but we're
ranked
number one in the videos category and so
if somebody's looking for a video that's
important and you can see here that
these first two are ads
so what google is doing is they're
saying hey this is so
relevant this particular video for the
keyword query data science for beginners
that we're going to
show it above the organic listings even
though it's a video
so the whole idea is to be found on
youtube and google because
you're increasing your visibility you're
increasing your chances of getting found
on both
search platforms so according to
backlinko google ranks
videos with keywords like how to
tutorials
so you know a lot of the videos that you
find on youtube
are going to be instructional based and
so what google's doing
is they're saying hey if somebody types
in how-to or
tutorial or an introduction to anything
that's going to
signal to google that it's instructional
it's going to help you rank so
when you search for machine learning
tutorial or how to become a machine
learning
engineer you're going to get results
related to that because if you look at
these examples
we have machine learning tutorial in our
title or how to
become a machine learning engineer so
keep that in mind
if you're creating a video and it's
educational in nature
you know use those key terms like how to
and tutorials in the video title because
that will help you rank so let's move
over now to video titles so
we want to use our target keyword
in the title of the video and again we
want to make sure if it's educational
to include that keyword tutorial or how
to
so for every video title youtube has a
limit of 100 characters
so we really have to pick and choose a
really wisely
so if we look at the video that we were
focusing on a couple of minutes ago
so machine learning basics here we could
see
under 100 characters we have machine
learning basics
what is machine learning introduction to
machine learning and then
the brand name so that is the title of
this particular video
so it takes into account the primary
keyword the secondary keywords
and the title and it also includes that
really that key
term that really google and youtube like
and that's what
is machine learning so it's helping us
rank
by having our keywords in the title with
that key phrase
what is okay so that's a good tidbit on
creating a good video title is to align
it with
the right keywords your primary and your
secondary and so we want to use those
catchy words and numbers to gain
high click-through rates just like you
would on the title tag of your web page
we want to do the same
with our video title because the video
titles what's going to show up
in search so if i go back to you know
search
here we could see you know data science
tutorial
data science for beginners so we want to
make sure in this case you can see data
science in five minutes
so that was purposely done so that hey i
don't have time to watch a video
i only have a couple minutes data
science in five minutes okay great i'm
gonna click on the video
and now i have an opportunity to watch
something and learn something under five
minutes
so choosing the right words in your
video title is going to help you get
that click-through rate up
remember click-through rate is clicks
divided by
impressions and an impression is how
many times your video shows up
in the search results on youtube or
google so we want to
keep our click-through rate high and in
order to do that we want to be able to
write some really good
title tags for our video so use catchy
words
like a number or how to or what is
because that's going to resonate with
people when they're searching now for
the description what we want to do
is we want to use the target word at the
beginning
of the description the title and the
tags itself so
if i go back to my video here machine
learning basics
we know it's in the video title and
right off the bat if i look at the
description of the video here i can see
this machine learning basics video will
help you understand what is machine
learning so
our primary keyword is in the first
sentence right in the introductory of
the description
and so that's going to bode well for
optimizing our video the description
length is 5 000 characters so we have a
lot of characters to work with so if i
go back to my video
i click show more we have a lot of
characters to really describe what the
video is about okay there's no
shortage no shortage of including
keywords into the content so you have 5
000 characters
go ahead and see if you can work in
naturally your keywords
but one of the key tips here is just
make sure
that first sentence starts out with that
keyword that's a good
tip of course you always want to make it
sound natural as possible
you don't want to stuff it with keywords
at the same time
work them in naturally work in your
keywords naturally and then include
hashtags in your description to help the
audience find your video
is easily so if i go back here you know
we want to be able to include hashtags
so hashtags it's like anything else you
would use on social media
it just signals to the end user hey this
is what the video is all about
and if i go ahead and type in that
keyword then it's our video has a better
chance because it's aligned with that
hashtag and then there's target keywords
and lsi keywords latent semantic
indexing keywords we want to be able to
use
those keywords as target keywords with
our video so
if you recall the example i gave a few
minutes ago
we used the facebook ads tutorial as our
example
here i could see all the target keywords
associated
with that particular video so don't be
afraid to use those
lsi related keywords meaning keywords
that are related to the content
use them as target keywords with the
video so between
your lsi keywords target keywords
and then using our primary and secondary
keyword
in the title tag using our primary and
secondary keyword
in the description and then using
hashtags in the description
the combination of all of that if we
chose the right keyword
then we should find that our video will
eventually rank on youtube so just doing
these small
tidbits with our keywords really help
get our video to rank
so at the end of the day we want to be
able to use the tools available to us
youtube itself by looking at our
competitors those extensions like vidiq
the autocomplete to really find our good
keywords
and then incorporating those keywords
into you know the title tag the
description
as target keywords hashtags we should
really be off and running with our video
on youtube
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel
and click here to watch similar videos
turn it up and get certified
click here